okay hello everyone welcome to another
of language design review part of our
incremental language development series
uh we seem to have three items for today
first is spherical geometry I've been
waiting for this for a long time
this is the earth as unit size or
something
uh
let's take a look
all right so
this is the analog of geo-distance but
with the unit sphere
presumably I'm with angles measured in
radians is that correct
yes
and actually I think that the measuring
the Angles and radians is a little bit
different than using the latitude
longitude coordinate system
it's a traditional latitude longitude
system
used in historical competition does that
mean that like latitude zero is at the
North Pole or something exactly yeah
correct so it's it's called attitude
right it makes sense
uh okay
so we have a ref page probably there the
simplest thing is to look at that
can I get something other oh yes but
wait a minute geodesic distance
oh we don't want a third argument which
is the radius
well well that's one of our questions
today
um I I've pers I've gone back and forth
on the design but then for this last
presentation version I've taken the
radius out just because I don't think it
adds very much
are we able to do an ellipsoid or is
that too hard
and does it require too much other
sort of equipment to do an ellipsoid I
I'm sure that we could do that because
we do it in other areas of the code like
it has to be done I think for geo
distance but the way that spherical
distance is programmed now it doesn't
accept
um eccentricity or anything like that in
any sort of deformation parameters yeah
it's also the case sorry it's also the
case that there would not be exact
formulas for the ellipse
even with electric functions I I mean
there are it just wouldn't be
um nobody cast type situation probably
it's Integrations of elliptic functions
so I'm not sure we have
close results
works with these VR oh that's really
nice this will work for for higher
dimensional spheres that's really nice
yeah well then so that's another problem
with the potential problem if we wanted
to do ellipsoids is that yeah yeah
forget it forget it it's way too
complicated I think it's much more
interesting okay so this
oh why aren't assuming that these are
real well yeah that's the other question
is do the other big question we have is
if we want to do complex values or if we
should just be restricted Mr real only
oh splatter rule here
so this this was I opened this in the um
prototype build
great
what happened it crashed
I looked like a front-end thing though
yeah yeah there's nothing to it but but
so sorry so the complex question whether
you you could have for example complex
radii for no complex
there's always one then the questions
about complex angles I don't think we
care about complex angles I think we're
going to have a separate hyperbolic
story
I mean what do complex angles mean
I mean we don't know and Jose and I have
been looking a little bit I mean let's
just not worry about that I think
okay great
I think it's much better to have
formulas that look reasonable and don't
aren't full of crud
than it is to support the complex case
where you know I just don't think that's
an important case I've never heard of
complex angles for this
so do we seem to support them in
rotation metrics and of course we do
have complexes in things like vector
angle
and things like that so yeah I
understand but I I think
I don't know why we support them in
rotation metrics
I mean Lawrence transformation somebody
might have thought that's what Lawrence
Transmissions are but they're not right
no it's not we have looked at the code
that and it's not
I mean just to give a sense of this
let's say how do we do this we'd say
assuming
what do we do here assuming a b
elementary
you can do simplify right
you need to simplify there
can we just do this
no I think you need to to add the
the element
okay
I don't think we need to even discuss
this I mean this is just like a and I
don't even understand okay this is right
because it has to do the wrap around
right yep
but I mean the other one is just silly
you know maybe we could have an
assumptions argument for spherical
distance if we really care but I think
we don't care
I think we should just assume they're
real
okay and we are out if we find complexes
do what sorry if we feed complex numbers
we are allowed I think so and what
what's the order of
the angles I mean is it consistent with
with
is it consistently consistent with
hyperspherical or is it it's what chord
HR data does except for removing the
first
argument which is the the first element
which is the radius
right but so it's doing so it's
in three dimensions is it consistent
with spherical or with hyperspherical
are those consistent
no because they're
uh
oriented differently right one the
spherical is a is a special case because
uh right it's oriented in Z maybe it
doesn't matter if you're if you're
intrinsic
this is a question of whether if you're
going from point A to point B
is that what you're talking about
so there was a convention here about
whether you put first all the feet
angles and then a Phi or all the five
angles and then Theta and things like
that oh oh okay okay okay okay okay okay
you're talking about
okay I understand what you're saying
you're saying in the
right is it Theta Phi which it would
normally be for the
you know
that's Co longitude co-latitude or
something is that right
it's that sort of thing I cannot
precisely state it right now but I and I
were quite careful about this in in
coordinate child data we should check
against it but
um Brad do you know yeah I I I'm pretty
sure we have checked against it we can
check again
um but I wasn't aware of what itai was
saying that maybe if we check coordinate
chart data for spherical and
hyperspherical with you know
three dimensions that they're not the
same
well certainly the embedding is not the
same maybe the order of the coordinates
is the same
yeah yeah so it's a little we can we can
figure it
by the way documentation wise why is it
the case
I mean it would seem great to me if we
did one of these things where we had a
list of you know a guide page of the
burst coordinate charts and then
separate documentation for each
coordinate you know for each coordinate
system
does that make sense
uh yeah I think
stuff is getting crammed in the details
here is that what you're trying to say
yeah that's what I'm trying to say I'm
trying to say I think it would be great
if there was a page specifically about
oblates for idle coordinates
okay well I don't know how to create
such a page but I know that I know that
but I mean look at for example I don't
know something like import okay
it has that listing of formats goes to
this then it goes to a special case page
type and that's a Brian
story to create those
okay
I like them very much we could reduce it
for projections and for frames in Astra
it's all the same type of idea yes let's
do it I think it'll much much clearer
okay
so because otherwise this is really hard
to extract what the hell
um I don't even know how to answer the
question that you were asking about what
the coordinates are
um
I don't know where is this even
spherical
you know the radius polar angle as a
mutant angle okay
and hyperspherical
the poles along the X1 axis
I I don't really understand this
that's why we need a longer
documentation page
okay
um
well what is the coordinate chart data
output if you call to it
um okay let's find out
so you're saying coordinate chart data
of spherical for example
well you'd need to give it you'd need to
give it a property like what property do
you want
coordinates
is that is that a property
yeah that's probably what range
assumptions would be
no that's not very useful I mean we like
what are the names of the goods that's
standard coordinate names
okay
boy this would do better on a separate
page okay that's all thetify
hyperspherical or what are what are the
scale factors or also probably pretty
good to look at and you may need to give
it yeah for hyperspherical you need to
tell it what dimension right so you need
list three
okay but now let's do four
yeah so PSI is probably another angle
like the Theta
um right yeah okay right so right it's
really only the embedding into R3 and
since we're doing intrinsic geometry it
doesn't matter I was momentarily
confused I mean this was a useful little
detour but I was mostly could you
explain that that I just so I understand
what you're talking about
so I mean the Theta in spherical
coordinates is the angle from the z-axis
right hyperspherical it's the angle from
the x-axis
really matter because yeah because
because well it matters it matters if
you're doing coordinate transform data
between hyperspherical and right but
these are intrinsic coordinates in data
Phi exactly and so it doesn't matter
right were you to convert
were you to take these coordinates we
need to take those points
and deduce them from Cartesian
coordinates
it's still not going to matter yeah it's
just gonna okay
distance is invariant under rotation
yes
okay
nice
is this nice and fast
it's pretty fast yeah I mean it's not
compiled but it's I think it it's about
as fast as it can be without being
compiled and then the array or the
Matrix usage has threat is threaded it
uses its own code so that's also even
faster
okay cool
all right
um
so just so I understand I'm just sort of
curious here
uh uh so if I say
like spherical distance
and I go from the North Pole so I say
table 0 n
here and I go to the
what would I have to do I would go to
table pi over two
is that right
is that all this
you're doing different hyperspheres
right yeah I'm doing different type of
spheres I'm asking a question
right what's the difference yeah yeah
what's the distance to the equator from
the poles
is it to the equator or is it some point
on the equator it's just to the
let's see if I just say well the every
point on the equator is probably
equidistant to the poles
yeah it's probably true
um
uh but right but the equator might
actually be an N minus one sphere or
something like that it'll be weird
because if yeah
but if you have two sphere the equator
is a one sphere
if you have a three I don't know I guess
the equator isn't too severe maybe yeah
right it is always You're just setting
one coordinate to zero yeah
and this is probably obvious that this
has to be the
if if you look at the scale factors
maybe but I don't know if we're going to
do that
what like go to coordinate chart data
and change standard coordinate names to
scale factors and see what it says
do we have a function for like like
random spherical position
like random geoposition
we don't yet the plan was to support the
opposition inputs here too interpreting
them as being on the unit sphere
I see so you would you could run random
geoposition which already probably uses
effectively a sphere and then uh just
feed those directly into this or I could
say random point
what about this if I say random points
oh the problem is it'll be different
coordinate system
right this this would return 3D
well we can't use the the we have
existing functions about
um the polar coordinates
no I think we have like two spherical
coordinates don't we yes I'm from
safaricon
yeah so here we see the problem that we
need to remove the radius right you you
want the rest of two spherical
coordinates yeah right it's got the um
to specify the dimension on the render
point
what do you mean the demand show fitted
sphere of four for example I think you
have to do sphere of zero zero zero zero
oh never mind never mind
you need this you need to use the you
need the two polar coordinates
so because
okay cool
now and and the reason for that is
precisely because of this embedding
issue because spherical is the odd man
out
yes I got it okay so fine so there are
some examples here that could be given
uh on the spherical distance page for
what it's worth in the in probably
somewhere down in the in the um boy it's
a lot of interesting things here and I
assume let me see
right it wouldn't be possible to
interpret these spherical coordinates
with the radius as uh
as spherical coordinates because you
can't tell whether the first number is a
radius or uh yeah
well yeah and then the other issue if
let's say we're going to change the
input format to just accept the vectors
is like what if somebody goes in there
and puts in one point with one radius
and another point with a different
radius than what yeah hopeless
I agree I don't think that's useful
um
okay let's keep going
uh
yeah I think we answered these so by the
way I assume we're going to eventually
have
uh
spherical list plot and all the various
I mean it will be well actually more
relevant here is something we don't have
for the geocase which is spherical plot
by taking a function and plotting it on
a sphere
am I making sense
yeah conversation what's that
visualization in Geo yes yeah 3D
visualization for on a sphere because I
think that is a fun you know a function
on a sphere right it shows up all over
the place in in um you know for all
sorts of applications where it's just a
function and there's also plotting data
on a sphere I mean basically spherical
density plots spherical list plot all
these things are reasonable things to
ask for
and then with with various projections
well there's kind of two things right I
mean there's like in the Geographics
case like there are several function
repository entries for basically
Geographics 3D quotes where it's not
really about plotting data it's just
about generic you know Graphics
Primitives right or Geographics
Primitives
I mean you could imagine a a spherical
Graphics or spherical plot no spherical
graphics 3D or something like that which
would you know you could have Primitives
in it where you give you a point of such
a section it would show up on the sphere
separately there's the you know a bunch
of visualization stuff
yeah
um the one thing I've done with this
next spherical triangles thing which the
spherical triangles is probably a pretty
good place to start with depiction even
following what Christopher said
is uh I did use the region functionality
to do depiction a quick depiction
function for spherical triangles but
so this is this here is a whole separate
idea that's related to
some other functions that we have about
solving
the data of plane triangles
and this is just a generalization of
that to the sphere or that adaptation of
that to the sphere where if you you have
a list of sides and you have a list of
angles and that list has some values
filled in and other values are left null
and if you have enough data that this
that the triangle is exactly determined
it will try to find populate the rest of
the data
and
um there's so some sometimes
in the plane triangles what function is
this well there's a whole range of them
I think yeah especially that's triangle
Etc
um so this there are a bunch of separate
case functions hidden in the source code
for this but I just made this one
spherical triangles thing accepts a
general template and figures out how to
solve it but so you've taken a different
design approach from I mean in the case
of uh plane triangles we just have
explicitly SAS triangle Etc yeah and I
don't know if we want to keep this
design approach or hide it but you know
for now it works and it does all it has
a lot of flexibility it does whatever
case
well I think it's interesting it's a
design idea we didn't have for ordinary
triangles I think
there are two important differences one
is that this is focused on The
Primitives
and the second thing is that the playing
case we are looking at we detected it
doesn't considered all cases and the
spherical case is even more complicated
because it has ambiguity sometimes so it
returns a list of two possibilities yeah
so actually actually the plane case the
the a the AAS I think plaincase can
return multiple results acute and obtuse
but that that one was never
or maybe it's side side angle
because there's one that's missing from
there's one plane case that seems to be
missing so can we try a side side angle
and see if that one is in there SSA
triangle
no so I think that one is missing and I
my my
understanding is that it's missing
because it doesn't fit this pattern of
one set of inputs result returning one
result well you could ask Michael I mean
or somebody who's it's um a standard
non-postulate
SSA
it's not it's not unique you get two
in general
right so I think that's true on a sphere
as well
sometimes yeah but so if
then the design Choice was well okay
because we can return to results instead
of always returning one that we
shouldn't we shouldn't
have that well I think it's perfectly
reasonable to have
I mean this is like functions of the
branch Cuts you know it's like
I'm not sure that there's a standard
you know of the two possible results
well I mean in the plain case there
surely is the acute triangle
well why is the acute one better than
the obtuse one I don't know but I mean
that's an obvious thing to return but my
question is
you know there's no good unless you can
get the other one
and maybe you can get the other one by a
side side angle you know a convention
like with Branch cuts that says if that
angle is greater than whatever then it's
the you know in the interior it's always
the interior angle or something well I
don't know how you'd do it but
but in order to you know to be able to
get the other Case by by changing that
angle
yeah
um from my basic experiments me not
being an expert in this field and just
sort of getting into it now it it's a
little bit uh there are things that I've
read conditions stated but in practice
it looks a little bit unpredictable to
me so the way that it's working right
now is a little bit unsophisticated but
we could potentially put more time into
working on the preconditions hold on
let's let's start thinking about these
things so
given one of these triangles
uh how do I find the area of the
triangle I mean so if if I've got an SSS
triangle here
let's say I've got this
and I go
you know so here
I mean
is there a meaning you could try to do
region measure since we calculated those
oh yeah or you could try it does area
work on
regions yes so you could try to do area
there but there's also a I think a very
simple formula for area which just has
to do with adding up the angles so if
your output is side side angle angle
angle you could easily get the area just
well I know but we want the function
that does it
you know that is the you know we want
the you know
all the stuff like the angle deficit all
these kinds of things yeah that's that's
definitely the next direction for this
particular part of the functionality
um but you know we just did this all
without much design input from anybody
else but let's let's step back for a
second okay
the next you know
spherical triangle is clearly important
okay
but
let's try to understand I mean clearly
plotting a function on the sphere is
obviously important other wfrs that do
that yet
anybody know
well there's certainly Geo ones but
that's all different
oh and my my go-to is parametric plot I
think first plotting things on this
parametric plot usually okay so but but
so the things we're going to need
are
there's like a stereographic projection
which is similar
okay
but I mean look to me we'll want
something that says just called
spherical plot that's just a function f
of Theta Phi
whoops
I mean we currently have the function
actually we have a spherical plot 3D
don't we
yes we do so what this does is
foreign
whoops
oh it needs data and Phi separately
okay
well but that is our that's the that's
the picking RS I know that's that's
that's Computing R so what we want
is more like spherical density plot
yes like how would we make a those
pictures of spherical harmonics or
whatever exactly
is its spherical density plot or is it
what's this
wait a minute oh this came from email
this didn't come from the oh Avery is
this
is this in
yeah it's in your Dropbox
you should have picked it up
you can just overwrite that one
no I'm going to I'm going to go and pick
it up from the other place
okay
okay so just looking at the spherical
okay so we want something that has
you know that in the end
is like plotting a function just like
geolist plot
plots
points I mean we'll we'll one presumably
spherical list plot
if I'm not mistaken
right which will take a list of points a
list of theta five pairs
and plot those points on the surface of
a sphere so for example if we say just
to give an example let's say sphere
points
you know
what oh yes
okay so here I might say graphics 3D
of point of that
okay but now I want to be able to plot
that
with the projection how would I do that
I mean I think we're going to want
something
where we can plot a function okay to
plot
okay how do I make okay that's several
different things I want to do okay
you know
plot
a function
or points on the sphere
using a projection
plot them on a 3D sphere
does that make sense what do you mean by
using a projection projecting on the
sphere or no on the plane like in the
real projection yeah right
so I mean in in for example in this case
here
presumably
I could do this in a somewhat bizarre
way so these sphere points
if I say two polar coordinates no two
spherical coordinates right
of those and I say rest slash at that
and then I say how do I make those into
Geo positions how do I make those into
Geo what's it I multiply by something
um did someone saying I divide by
degrees I think
yes
um
well it's also co-latitude and isn't it
well it doesn't really matter in this
case
so let's say geolist plot
of point
no Geo just GLS pi
of those values
and maybe you need your position we will
need that reverse because your position
is going to come it's going to be
latitudes of 150
so okay so it's in Reverse of that
exactly
okay
no it's still it's reverse
maybe it's because it's co-latitude and
it's do you need geoposition around each
one of the points no no no but but you
see we have a 153 as first element that
that cannot be that cannot be a Latitude
so we need we need to oh we have a 137
in the second no something right yeah no
I think it's because it's a it's because
it's the co-latitude isn't it so zero to
180 instead of minus 90 to 90. yes so
what do we do we subtract we add 90 to
it or something or subtract 90 sorry
yeah
but why doesn't this wrap around
no latitudes cannot wrap around
what do I do I say I say of this I say
um plus threaded
exactly I think it's threaded of
zero
present of 90 0 minus that array
90 0 minus Theory
yes
there you go
okay that's actually pretty cool I mean
the fact it has the Earth on it is kind
of stupid but
but that's what we're looking for right
given those points
given the thing it's only that whole
transformation you know
should be you know there should be some
simpler way to do it
yeah we don't need it because if we've
got actual spherical coordinates we're
not going to be messing around with G or
anything no no but it's useful to be
able to convert between the Geo you know
representation and the spherical
representation and as we can see it's a
little bit fiddly
yes that's true yeah I kind of agree
with Christopher on that one but for
this plot here I'm in the bigger
question for me is okay what are we
going to do when we start linking the
points together do we want them linked
geodesically
just like we have geopath
okay now the difference of design here
is that we don't have the notion of a
spherical point we just have naked
coordinates
yeah is that I think that's fine why not
it probably is fine I mean I think but
we have to but that means that when we
represent a geopath
so I'm saying that then we've got to
have a specific thing called spherical
path because we don't have that concept
if we have line unless we decide that
line on a sphere means the geodesic
that might be possible
what do other people think about that I
mean line here would not mean that so if
I said here I think that's too
inconsistent the fact that line means
one thing and and what happens if I say
if I say line can I say line
here what do I have to say I think you
need Geographics
yeah so already in Geo we interpret
differently lines of geopositions and
geopaths of geopositions
lines are always made of straight
segments
where Straight is defined how
yeah just in the projection you are
working
okay
that's a pretty amusing picture actually
so that so that's geodesics between
every point exactly nice
um
okay so I mean this is clearly a thing
we're going to need now the other thing
we're going to need which we don't have
you said we do have it in a wfr for geo
cases the function on the sphere
well it's spherical plot 3D is almost
that in the sense that if you add a
radius to your function then you are
already representing
deviations with respect to that radius
I understand so if you say for example
for this thing here but that's a
different way of plotting it because I
think what I'm looking for is something
where it's a 2d projection
of the 3D like like you know the plots
you always see of the cosmic microwave
background
I see so you are still thinking about 2D
plots yes so so the thing there is what
would have are the concept of functions
on the sphere like the equivalent of
interpolating function on the sphere and
things like that
wow this is a mess let's say I go 30 or
something here
yeah then I mean that's not very useful
but but that um
and I probably add a color function or
something
okay but so yes so that's what I'm
saying I'm saying I'm saying what if you
give an analytical function
okay there are two points you're making
we don't have interpolation on the
sphere
which is a big deal around the polls and
things like that but if I just gave you
a function right for example a spherical
harmonic
I should be able to plot that spherical
on the sphere
a 2d projection of that but as a radius
function or as a color function
well I mean here as a color function
because it's like a density plot
right so I should be able to plot
whatever the spherical harmonic is I
mean if I say circle look let's do this
if I say spherical harmonic
uh y of I don't know five two
how does it work is it five two like
that
or is it five two anybody know
LM Theta Phi okay so it's this
thing here
okay so what I'm looking for here
is
we're evaluating this for many values of
data and Phi
what what
um uh I just put something uh from
Michael in the chat there that might be
helpful
yes that's very helpful
right so what we're looking for is well
we we probably want this case as well
but you're actually showing it on a
sphere in 3D right but we also want this
case
where it's been flattened out to a
projection
am I making sense
yep
but but the the source for this is
just like density plot I mean we're
going to want both the list case and the
India we already have the list case
which we call unfortunately Geo density
plot not Geo list intensity plot
I I've thought we should change that
name
and maybe there's a way to do that
compatibly
I I think Geo I think the basis here was
that in the majority of cases the real
data is is data not functions
dovetail with spatial statistics stuff
they have their own representation
functions
um they have a powerful point value plot
I think it's called yes
I think we need to worry about that and
I think we need to consider you know we
could compatibly change this because
geodensity plot if it's given a function
right if it's given this it could
produce the right result and complain
and give a message
to get what I'm saying yes I think this
is a discussion that would need bread
fine but I I my suggestion is that we
plan to change this to geo-less density
plot and make geodensity plots going
forwards primarily be a function based
thing
but you know spherical density plot
is surely the thing that we need
look but what I would assume we need a
spherical density plot
which is the projection version
and then spherical density plot 3D which
is the version with an actual sphere
does that make sense
and then
we're presumably going to need spherical
list plot
and we might as well have Circle this
plot 3D but but the thing that that's
not dealing with
oh boy is the case of Primitives on the
sphere right which would be something
more like spherical graphics
and spherical graphics 3D
that's what I'm saying and that would be
okay except for the fact that for
example a triangle which we have is a
perfectly meaningful thing
and you know
look I don't know I mean I'm kind of
thinking
that we might need functions like
spherical path
and spherical triangle
or spherical polygon or something
functions are like containers rapid
containers
well yeah I think we will have to unless
we're willing to double use the
containers that we already have but
sound like some containers which ones
other than polygon polygon line but it
sounds like people didn't like that idea
look if we had these it also allows us
the possibility of saying for spherical
polygon we can just say area of
spherical polygon
be kind of nice
yeah
yep
and then
if we have that spherical polygon
wrapper
why doesn't that subsume the spherical
Triangle stuff
oh I see because you have an angle
specification there right
specification is quite different yeah so
the the way the flow would work for
calculating area is like let's say that
you have a spherical polygon and inside
there's a list of angular points well
maybe you find the centroid to break it
down into spherical triangles get used
no I understand I understand the
algorithm but I'm the question is
spherical polygon would literally take
Theta Phi values for the points around
the polygon right yep I think so yeah is
it unique
given the Theta Phi values does that
Define I guess we we have to Define just
like we have to define a bow tie
handling rule in 2D right we'll have to
define the analog of a bow tie handling
rule for spherical polygons it's
slightly more complicated you need to
decide whether it's the inside or the
outside right so if you leave the points
of the Equator which side do you mean
right
so that's why geopolygon for example
takes an interior point or an exterior
point or as a second argument or
something yes or a left rule or right
rule we're going to have to copy that
that behavior basically
[Music]
right so we should just copy that exact
Behavior
but does it does it assume that the
you know can't it assume the polygon
you're talking about has minimal area
yeah that's the smaller area case
exactly there are multiple ways of
specifying it and
it will deduce one from the others
okay and this now already has these
things which are also very sensible
is that right I mean that that defines
but and these fear they are all the same
basically and on the ellipsoid the the
six and and great circles are different
Ram lines are still different yes yeah
okay so it looks like we needed a
spherical polygon that is the analog of
geopolicon what other Primitives do we
have for geo
oh gosh we have geodisk as well
yes and you're gonna need all these I
don't see how we're going to get away
with that please well and remember that
we also have this Astro family so if
there was a way in which we could at
least merge right now we have the
regions
family Geo Astro and now potentially
spherical too
so I don't think we should merge them
I think I think it's going to be too
confusing
and perhaps in Australia I mean it's
really it's rare that you use poly
Primitives in Astro but just for a
moment
and
perhaps you can reuse these vertical
ones yes I think we could right because
people imagine you know there's a
concept of spherical astronomy and
things like that whatever exactly yeah
it really is a sphere there's no there's
no
despite the universe maybe not expelled
does expand more or less in the same
little directions so it is you know it's
a sphere all the way down
um
so I agree I think reusing the spherical
ones for Astro makes sense
because
you know for example for the cosmic
microwave background which by the way
might be another
I mean at some point just as we have
those backgrounds like the galactic
background we could have the um you know
Cosmic microwave temperature profile as
a background in Astro
indeed we are looking for those images
it's just it's difficult to find them
with with good enough Precision but we
want them in in every
um wavelength X-rays and things like
that
right but I mean the reason that's
interesting is you know
what is it we're back to 130 million
years after the big bang of Galaxy
there's a galaxy known
galaxies that are formed by that time so
at that point it becomes quite
interesting to plot those galaxies
against the temperature variations in
the cosmic Aqua background
so now it's kind of silly if you're if
you're doing if you're doing a current
star in our galaxy plotting it against
the you know temperature fluctuations in
the CMB is kind of silly yeah but it
isn't by the time it's that far back but
but I was also thinking recently it'd be
awesome if we could do the parameter
extraction in like uh a one-liner it's
probably not possible but maybe
extraction
well you know taking the the power
spectrum of the CMB and trying to get
the age of the universe out
I don't see that the power Spectrum
doesn't give you that
no power Spectrum just tells you
fluctuations
okay maybe I'm confused about something
I mean the the we we do have a standard
Universe thing which gives you all the
stuff about you know the redshift versus
this like for example I'm sure that if
we say standard Universe actually I'm
I'm now I'm now curious because
uh I was sort of surprised at the thing
I was reading
um
work
oh cool asaurus
that's what I was wondering I mean the
thing I read was talking about 130
million years after the big bang and it
didn't give the freaking redshift
well there we have it nice
that is not the most beautiful graphic
and by the way I bet that's wrong now
and somebody should point that out to
Jeff
that makes sense Jose Avery maybe
somebody I think that station has
changed
yeah who was duck to him but this is
very nice that it just generates this
okay any case that's irrelevant to us
right now
um
okay so if we do this the one
functionality we're missing which is
what you've already put in Brad is a
triangle deducing a triangle from angles
right
um this is a triangle from its Edge from
its Corner coordinates
right okay
right so that that's not the same as
like SSS triangle which by the way is a
disembodied triangle not saying where it
is on this on the you know on the plane
uh yes but if you look at the example
there it project IT projects it to a
particular orientation
it's picking a particular place to put
the triangle that starts at the origin
yep
so so this return format
is actually different than the return
format for my spherical triangles thing
because it's like immediately depictable
I think all you have to do is hit that
with graphics and it becomes
right which it seems to me okay so hold
on let's just look at this
we're good to have some sort of
spherical triangle solve with properties
and some properties put
be give me the triangle back
as a graphics primitive yeah I mean it'd
be nice to have it somehow consistent
with the planar case
okay when you have a spherical triangle
I mean the thing I'm most used to is
things like the area deficit of a
spherical triangle blah blah blah
I mean by the way I mean we would have a
slightly peculiar spherical disc here
as we call it spherical cap
right same as we would you know we have
a sparkle disk with a Theta Phi Center
and a radius right
does that make sense people
yeah it will have the third argument as
disk with the beginning and final SMS
so that we can consider sectors too yes
yes yes yes yes
right just like presumably geodesk does
yes indeed
now I mean we presumably need a
spherical area as well because the area
if I'm not mistaken area in the geocase
am I confused here area is the slicing
through the Earth area is that true no
it's the area on the surface but what's
jail area
sorry no giordia is this is the area on
the surface yes on a geodisc calls you
area
so if I say area of geodisk oops
of geodisc
let's say
you know New York
uh 100 miles for example
why isn't that a correct region
but I say Geo area
yes I thought this would
I thought we decided that didn't work
because we thought that area should be
the slice through the Earth area in some
way
um no your area was the cap area
no I don't think so I thought this was
working I have to consult with with
chance so the idea is that the the
geoprimitives would be interpreted as
the corresponding curved Primitives in
in 3D but then area would go and say oh
this is a 2d primitive in 3D so I
compute the area and give it the same
result perhaps in a different units
the edges in the area case are they
geodesics or not
this is a bunch of geodesics
starting all from the Sim Center oh no
no but I'm sorry if I what I meant was
area of something which is a geopolygon
or a polygon
oh I'm confused if we give a polygon on
the sphere on the geoid
does the polygons edges on the geoid are
they geodesics
yes
um
well okay so I mean I don't understand
why we're not just having it okay the
the only difference is
we think it's useful an analog to the
planar triangle case to have like an sas
spherical triangle
right which we do not have an sas
spherical
s-a-s Geo triangle
although we could make it with bearings
and things could we not well into more
details hello sorry somebody's
somebody's talking hello hello hello
somebody needs to commute
okay
uh
okay what are we saying so
so ideal primitive
is always defined on the surface of the
Earth and when we go to the regions
world what what we do is to convert it
into a 2d region or mesh embedded in 3D
I understand I understand so I'm asking
the question what Brad has been working
on is things like SAS spherical
triangles
but at the present time in the geocase
we do not have a convenient way to give
angle-based triangles do we
no we don't we we have only geopolygon
that takes the vertices
right
yeah although we do have zero Direction
right but I think that the geocase is a
little bit more complicated because of
the ellipticity thing you know I know
that but the thing is okay the point is
the use case the the case of
you know okay so historical what do
people use spherical triangles for
I mean clearly they use them go ahead
the nice thing about the spherical
triangles is a rotational invariance of
the sphere is a similar property to the
translation and variance of the plane
so when you cut when you give this
specific data it will hold when the per
the points are put anywhere on the
sphere similarly when the points are put
anywhere in the plane and I don't think
that's probably not the case with
ellipsoids or anything obviously not
obviously not right but I mean my
question is a different question right
in
in sort of basic general relativity type
stuff
you know it's very it's very common case
to want to look at area deficits and so
on in or angle deficits and triangles
that kind of thing it's a standard sort
of illustration of curvature space Etc
et cetera but
I mean people had studied spherical
triangles obsessively surveyors had
studied I mean I think
like in if you look back at a book from
100 years ago
there'll be all kinds of stuff about
spherical trigonometry what was that for
was that for the Earth was that for you
know idealized spheres was that for
astronomy
who knows I would say as Geo and
astronomy were the two main motivators
of that interest
but why was spherical triangles
important
is important for surveyors yes yes I
mean if you have a large enough area of
the Earth you have to use curved
geometry and at that point in which
doing an ellipsoidal geometry was so
incredibly difficult they tended to do
first the spherical approximation and
then have I see the other duration
formulas and the reason that spherical
triangles were important is if you're
surveying a large area you're going to
do it with triangles you're going to
have a triangle decomposition is that
right
exactly yeah for example the first time
that they separated small Parcels of
area in the U.S around 1800 they already
took into account the curvature of the
Earth
to do very tiny mild size computations
so like in Kansas or something when they
were uh you know for the whatever it was
the land rush or whatever whatever that
whole thing was yeah yeah there is this
story that the government bought a large
area of the US and then made it into
small pieces and sell it to their to the
citizens right and so they have to be
very careful with those pieces but so
that surveying was done
so at that time people cared about
spherical triangles because they
surveyed it in triangles is that true
well perhaps inquired wrangles but they
certainly took into account the fact
that they were working with meridians
that were approaching towards the polls
okay but I mean my question is
the concept of putting in
a spherical triangle as opposed to a
spherical polygon clearly a spherical
polygon is something we need and
specifying it by its actual Theta Five
Points on sphere we understand we need
that now Brad has done an additional
thing here which is to specify triangles
using angles using combinations of
distance and angles right which is the
equivalent of using geodirection on the
earth is it not
it's related so I think the problem
comes from the fact that when you do
quadrangles in in curved geometry you
end up doing a lot of trigonometry so
what Brad has done is the equivalent of
trigonometry in the flat plane but on
the sphere
yeah go ahead and I will just add that I
think it's going to be useful in a
workflow of once we have the spherical
polygons
breaking them down and measuring them by
uh turning them into a sets of spherical
triangles no doubt but the question is
whether sourcing the triangle because
you've got a completely new and
different way of sourcing triangles with
those nulls and things in it
right so we don't have to we might
eventually hide that but yeah I
understand that I understand but but so
it's it's an interesting idea which
perhaps we could also apply in 2D I mean
in flat space
but I want to understand geo-direction
because to me what you're doing is
you're saying you're giving a sequence
of geo-directions I mean we could
specify a polygon in
a geopolygon by saying the start point
and then a series of geodirections very
similar to what angle path does
except angle path is just one you know
it's just a a you know a 1D object
is that is that making sense
yes the other direction is indeed
equivalent to the problem of given three
points find the angle
that one sees the other two
right but I mean so okay
to me
it seems like there's more
these things we've got on the screen
right now seem more
obviously usable
than the point and angle point and
bearing based
version of spherical triangles I think
but I might be missing something
uh you you had raised spherical
interpolation function
which I think is a yet a separate thing
am I making sense
yep but that's a um
and we don't yet have Geo interpolate
although we could
yeah so that that's something that the
statistics team have been looking at
I see but I mean they they effectively
have that oh I see they don't have that
they only have Point processes and
things on the plane is that true
yes so what they do is to convert into
an equilateral projection in which the
interpolation preserves area which is
the most important thing for that uh
that seems like a fine process
implementation and then and then convert
back
it depends on what you are interested in
if you're interested in preserving
length because you are interpolating a
longer line yeah then an equal
um I mean other projections might be
more
Equity Styles projections
so you're but you're saying potentially
there's a spherical interpolate which
contains in it some kind of uh uh
spherical projection
exactly for example random geoposition
takes a projection in which you want
homogeneity because pointing in
homogeneous in one projection will not
be uniform sorry it would not be uniform
in another projection
yeah okay so spherical interpolate and
Geo interpolate would have to do the
same thing
um
but to me the first step is you know the
spherical
plot
okay so wait a minute so we've also got
spherical no we've got spherical density
plot
which is producing
the flattened version of this right and
spherical density plot 3D is producing
basically this
does that make sense
yes yeah I think that's a good starting
Place actually or continue Point okay so
can I can I raise one more question
what about the hyperbolic case
uh personally I think it's really
important but I'm biased because I spent
a lot of time studying algebraic curves
so okay about hyperbolic triangles in
relation to this Riemann uniformisation
theorem okay but but hold on I just want
to know design wise okay
if we had just like we have spherical we
had hyperbolic as another family here
to the things we've been discussing make
sense for the hyperbolic case
like does hyperbolic distance make sense
I think it does doesn't it
yes but we are entering the domain of
arbitrary
metric what about you know projective
spaces or some other type of
well but I think hyperbolic space is
just one that is you know like like a
sphere is important well we happen to
live on one but you know spheres are
important because we make them all the
time you know clearly just like we said
it's not really as important to do
ellipsoid stuff as it is to do the
sphere case
I think you know one day maybe we have
the arbitrary metric case but I think
the hyperbolic case is clearly much more
important
than the arbitrary metric
does that make sense but but my
understanding of the hyperbolic case is
that there isn't just one hyperbola in
the same way that there's one sphere or
they're not one hyper hyperbolic
manifold in the same way that there's
one sphere or one plane I thought they
were just different models of hyperbolic
space
am I confused anybody here know that
I mean like the supply disc and there's
the various other models but I thought
that there was
established with
perhaps in in N dimensions
just like right that's the analog of you
know that's the differently signed
euclidean metric
and I mean for mathematical uses I mean
because because the case that I can see
is a variety of of um
uh
you know for example hyperbolic
visualization
you know visualize a tree in hyperbolic
space
and that would work in the you know that
that's going to just work in minkowski
space right that's not that doesn't
require any other and then there's a
question of what is the
I don't quite understand the difference
between the quotes model of hyperbolic
space like the Monterey disc
versus
a projection
it's some kind of generalized projection
yes something like that
they may have the wrong set of people
here to answer this I I was thinking so
I I've seen Ian investigate in
hyperbolic representations of trees in
which all the nodes get very uh close to
each other near the border of a disk
right yeah
um
yeah we're gonna explore those things
just it's an enormous world of of
rotations of multiple new things to
consider right but I mean okay so we
have in the function Repository
yeah we have a bunch of things here
hyperbolic distance look at that
huh
I see
well
things to look at here I'm just trying
to understand whether I'm just trying to
look ahead to see all the design we're
making for the spherical case it's going
to be insanely different for the
hyperbolic case
oh yeah
right
okay we should probably wrap up here
sorry we did not get to the other topics
for today
uh
but do we have uh is this I mean clearly
spherical distance looks like it's good
to go
and now I think we need to be tackling
some of these other spherical functions
okay uh we will explore with bread a bit
I think he he needs to be involved in
any of this yes but I I tend to think
that we need these rappers vertical
paths vertical polygon and so on
um
I don't think we need a spherical point
I don't think but I don't know for sure
what would happen if we didn't yeah go
ahead
um maybe the next next thing to do is
try and
um take some of these wrappers and show
how they would work with the spherical
triangles thing for extracting property
information
maybe I mean I I'm just not convinced
that the look
your scheme for how spherical triangles
are represented is quite interesting and
potentially applicable to plane
triangles but we're not going to have it
for spherical triangles and not for
plain triangles
see what I'm saying
do you want those functions then to look
more like the plane case or I don't know
because I don't know how spherical
triangles are used
I mean my speculation is that they were
used by surveyors or possibly astronomy
people
but I think more likely surveyors you
know 100 plus years ago
and I don't know how they used today I
just don't know so we need to find that
out
I mean I guess this is called spherical
try is this plural spherical triangles
but uh yeah because it possibly returns
more than one right but I I would expect
spherical triangle or or even
you know I will to be more like triangle
where you just give it three vertices
and possibly additional information
because you need to choose an Insider an
outside etc etc
um yeah we don't have a final name for
this either and Jose has already
suggested you know maybe adding solve to
the name for it so that it's clear so
something's being solved here
another name I thought of was uh
spherical triangle completions
I don't think we know what spherical
triangles are used for we need to figure
that out
before we go I I don't know whether this
design makes sense
but we need to understand more about
what spherical triangles are used for
because if really all we're trying to do
yeah
you know look I know from the 1960s for
example books of tables always had
sections on spherical triangles
I never used them once
I don't know what they used for
am I making sense just like they have a
sign function for example which appears
here right see that have a sine function
yeah I mean my my basic understanding is
it's similar to the Simplex thing
yes I understand that but it may be that
this was a method that was important
when you were doing by you know
surveying with chains and the other
lights and things like this right but
it's irrelevant today just like have a
sign is not a function any of us have
used I believe does anybody here used
have a sign
yes to improve the Hammer sign ref page
not outside
this context of Geon and that's Freckle
geometry but I guess the the point here
is when do you need spherical geometry
and there are I know design of antennas
you are designing your solar panels
exactly exactly there are places where
functions on the sphere are very
important
spherical triangles I don't know about
I don't know if you use spherical
triangles in antenna design I think you
do not you certainly use functions you
know F of Theta Phi you know power I of
Theta Phi is absolutely used integrals
over that things like this
but perhaps we are focusing too much on
a spherical triangles
that was the design problems yeah but
what I mean is that X Factor triangles
are used to do spherical trigonometry so
the important thing is that you have
sites and you need to compute angles Etc
and to visualize that and to work with
that you use triangles but the the main
thing you're going to get is not the
triangle itself but the angles or the
sides okay but I don't even know that I
don't even know that you get the angles
and sides I just don't know
give me an example where you get there
you don't get that an antenna design
well I mean if you want to see the area
of of that is is covered by by the
circle of the antenna from a given point
of view right so you need some sort of
I understand but I don't think it's
spherical triangles I don't know I I
think spherical triangles are creatures
of an earlier period in how surveying
was done might be wrong but let's try
and determine that before we spend
before we invent a whole giant mechanism
for dealing with spherical triangles
inconsistent with our mechanism for
dealing with plane triangles let's find
out the plane triangles we know that SAS
SSS and so on are important because
that's how people learn about triangles
yes but the point with those triangles
is that you are feeding information
about sides and angles and you are
getting back something that is placed
somewhere so there is some sort of
arbitrary decision yes I want to place
it and where to orient it the design
that Brad was presenting here is most of
consistent in the sense that you you
play with I get it I get it I get it
which means that we potentially should
use it for playing triangles as well
yeah so in the end if we visualize the
triangle we've got to place it somewhere
and I've got to go
um
this is nice stuff Brad
thank you I mean this is good
we're finally off and running with the
spherical stuff
um okay to be continued see you guys
soon bye